[Música]
En 1968 el doctor Robert enfermó luego
de cenar en un restaurante chino
escribió una carta sobre sus síntomas a
una revista médica reflexionando sobre
si su enfermedad derivaba de comer
glutamato monosódico o gms la conexión
entre su dolor de cabeza y este
condimento muy común en la gastronomía
china estadounidense fue solo una
corazonada pero su carta cambiaría
drásticamente la relación de todo el
mundo con el gms provocando pánico
internacional sesgos en la ciencia y
periodismo sensacionalista Durante los
siguientes 40 años entonces qué es este
misterioso condimento De dónde viene Es
realmente malo para usted
el gms es una mezcla de dos moléculas
simples el sodio que constituye una
parte fundamental de nuestra dieta y el
glutamato un aminoácido muy común que se
encuentra en varias proteínas vegetales
y animales juega un papel clave en la
digestión la función muscular y el
sistema inmunitario en la época de la
carta del doctor quak fue identificado
como una parte importante de la química
del cerebro el cuerpo produce suficiente
glutamato para todos estos procesos pero
la molécula también está presente en
nuestra dieta puede notar su sabor
característico en distintos Alimentos
como champiñones queso tomate y caldo la
búsqueda de este delicioso sabor llevó a
la creación del gms en 1908 un químico
japonés llamado doctor y queda kikunae
estaba intentando aislar la molécula
responsable de un sabor único que llamó
umami y que significa un sabor agradable
y sabroso actualmente el umami es
reconocido como uno de los cinco gustos
básicos en la ciencia de los alimentos
cada uno se produce mediante mecanismos
moleculares únicos que no se pueden
reproducir combinando otros Sabores
conocidos en el caso del umami esos
mecanismos aparecen cuando cocinamos o
fermentamos ciertos alimentos
descomponiendo sus proteínas y liberando
aminoácidos como el glutamato Pero y
queda encontró un sabroso atajo para
producir esta reacción química al aislar
grandes cantidades de glutamato de un
tazón de caldo de fideos y mezclarlas
con otro potenciador de sabor como el
sodio creó un condimento que aumentaba
al instante el umami de cualquier plato
el resultado fue un gran éxito en la
década de 1930 el gms era un alimento
básico en la mayor parte de Asia y A
mediados de siglo xx formaba parte de la
producción comercial de alimentos en
todo el mundo por cuando se publicó la
carta del doctor quoke el escándalo fue
inmediato los investigadores y los
ciudadanos exigieron investigar
científicamente el popular condimento
esto no era descabellado la sustancia no
había sido probada para determinar su
toxicidad y sus efectos en la salud eran
desconocidos aún así es probable que
muchas personas no reaccionaran a la
falta de seguridad alimentaria sino al
título de la carta síndrome del
restaurante chino si bien el gms se
usaba en numerosas cocinas muchos
estadounidenses tenían prejuicios de
larga Data sobre los hábitos
alimentarios asiáticos y los etiquetaban
de exóticos o peligrosos estos estigmas
aumentaron el sesgo racial en el
periodismo y el temor de que comer en
restaurantes chinos puede enfermarlo
este informe prejuicioso se extendió a
varios estudios sobre el gms y el umami
cuyos resultados fueron mucho menos
concluyentes de lo que sugerían los
titulares por ejemplo cuando un estudio
de 1969 descubrió que inyectar gms a
ratones dañaba gravemente la retina y el
cerebro algunos medios de comunicación
difundieron que comer gms podría causar
daño cerebral Aunque algunos estudios
informaron que el glutamato podría
causar problemas como el alzheimer luego
se descubrió que eran causados por
desequilibrios internos de glutamato no
relacionados con el gms que ingerimos
estos titulares no fueron solo producto
de reporteros prejuiciosos A fines de
los 60 y principios de los 70 muchos
médicos consideraban que el síndrome del
restaurante chino era una enfermedad
real afortunadamente Los investigadores
de hoy ya no juzgan a este condimento de
manera discriminatoria estudios actuales
establecieron el papel que desempeña el
glutamato en nuestro metabolismo Incluso
se considera que el gms es más saludable
que la grasa y el sodio agregado otros
están investigando si el consumo regular
de gms podría estar relaciona con la
obesidad Y si es posible que el consumo
compulsivo de gms produzca dolores de
cabeza de pecho o palpitaciones pero
para la mayoría de los comensales una
cantidad moderada de este sabroso
condimento Parece ser una forma segura
de hacer la vida un poco más sabrosa
como la historia da forma a los
alimentos que comemos conozca la
centenaria tradición del té y cómo se
extendió por todo el mundo con este
video o rastree la fascinante historia
del chocolate desde sus orígenes
antiguos en Mesoamérica con este video